- [Voiceover] Hey grammarians.
So last time we talked
about Raúl the penguin,
and how he was happier than
another penguin, Cesar.
But I wanna talk today about
how to form the comparative
and the superlative.
How to compare, how to
say something is more than
or most in an unfamiliar
situation, if you're looking
at a word for the first time
or you're trying to figure out
how to make a word
comparative or superlative.
To be like, oh well
I've got this word cute,
like that's a cute little
baby penguin, but how do I say
that it is more cute than another animal.
Well, there's a shorthand for that.
Sometimes you can say
more cute, certainly.
But you can also say cuter.
And you can furthermore say cutest.
And it turns out that there
are a series of sound rules
in English that govern the
way that we choose to make
these words go.
So I'll show you each of them in turn.
So we've got this little
table that I'm building here,
and we've got the description,
how it looks in the
comparative, and how it
looks in the superlative.
So if you take a word like cute,
words like cute have one
syllable, one word sound.
Cute.
So a word like cute, that is
one syllable and ends in an E.
All we have to do to make it comparative
is add an R.
So, add R, and that gives us cuter.
For the comparative, all
you have to do is add ST,
and you get the word cutest.
But what if you have a word like big?
If you try to add just R to
that, it would just look like
bigr, or ST to that, it would
look like bigst, and that's
not really how we would
form these words in standard
English, that doesn't go because they're
inconvenient to say, we like
to have vowels in between
some of those consonant
sounds, between the b and the g
and the st, so what you
do, if it's one syllable
and if it's got one vowel in
the middle like I, like that,
one vowel, and it ends in
a consonant like a G, then
what you do is double
the consonant and add ER.
So this word big ends in a
G, so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna, for the
comparative, I'm gonna say big,
and then I'm gonna double that
G, I'm gonna use it twice.
Bigger.
Like that, and then add the ER.
Likewise for the superlative, same thing.
So you double the consonant
at the end of the word,
and then you add EST, so
it becomes BIG and then
I double this consonant
sound, so BIGGEST, biggest.
And for words like short and sweet,
oh I should clarify.
For this one, for big, this
should end in one consonant.
So BIG, there's only one
consonant there, because
for words like short and
sweet that have one syllable,
but either have two vowels like
sweet does, so it's E and E
or two consonants at the end,
what you do is you just add ER
so shorter or sweeter.
And for the superlative form, add EST.
So shortest or sweetest.
And now we're getting
into the weird stuff.
So if you take a word like
shiny, which is two syllables,
and it ends in Y, then what you have to do
is you change Y into an I, and you add ER.
So shiny becomes shinier.
See how this Y becomes and I here?
Same thing for superlative,
the Y becomes an I,
and then you add EST, so shiniest.
Now, if you've got a
word like magnificent,
magnificent, this is a four syllable word,
it means like super huge,
super great, super wonderful,
you've got a word like that,
you take a word like that,
it's a little bit too big
to be adding more parts to
the way that standard
American English works.
So you wouldn't say
magnificenter, or magnificentest.
It just sounds unwieldy,
'cause the word's already
pretty long, so if you've got
a two or more syllable word,
that doesn't end in Y, then
you just have to add the word
more to the beginning,
so more magnificent, and
most magnificent.
So let's say that you're
encountering a word you've
never seen before.
And in a sentence you have to
compare, let's say the word
is blarfy, I don't know what it means,
probably something gross.
So if we wanna compare
two really gross meals,
like a steaming pile of
dog food covered in flies,
or a plate of ancient
cheese that 3000 years old.
You gotta eat it, gross.
Which one is grosser?
But you have to describe
them using the word blarfy,
this word we've never seen before.
Well, what do we know about blarfy?
Well, it's got two syllables, blarfy,
so that automatically crosses
out any of this stuff,
it does end in a Y, blarfy,
so we know that it's
probably going to behave like
shiny, like the word shiny,
because it's got two
syllables and it ends in Y.
So, I'm gonna say that the
dog food is less blarfy,
and the cheese is blarfier,
in fact this cheese
is the blarfiest food on the planet.
Now don't get me wrong, I
love a good stinky cheese,
but this one in particular,
this 3000 year old cheese,
super blarfy, in fact, I'm
just gonna go so far as to say
it is the blarfiest.
You can blarf anything.
David out.